hello and woke up the cloud on air live
webinars from google cloud i'm nikhil
code hardy an engineering lead on google
cloud platform
leading the ml engine team we're hosting
these live webinars every Tuesday
throughout this talk you can enter your
questions and my colleague Dinesh
Kulkarni who is a product manager on the
team will be will be able to answer
we'll also take some live Q&A at the end
of this talk so with that let's get
started with the presentation machine
learning is all around us these days
data scientists and developers are doing
some really creative things with their
data and powering some really
interesting machine learning use cases
one way to look at machine learning is
is through the lens of the data that
that you might use for your problem and
this data might be unstructured data
like images or it might be the more
familiar structure tabular data and new
and upcoming is also time series and and
sequential data another way to look at
machine learning is the business
problems that you might tackle and these
might range from perception and
understanding of this of all this
content depowering search to doing
things like recommendation as well as
estimation of price and risk in various
businesses or things like anomaly
detection fraud detection and so on
cloud ml engine allows you to tackle
your machine learning use cases with
your data ml engine in a nutshell is
about tensorflow as a service it allows
you to do predict training and
prediction which are the two most
important aspects of machine learning as
a managed service it provides api's but
for these two building blocks training
and prediction and allows you to bring
your data and your models to to the
problem taking a deeper slightly deeper
look at these two parts of the product
training is all about bringing to you
the capabilities to build your best
model at the best performance using
tensorflow you can you can avail
yourself of scaleable and distributed
trained
that that scales to the largest of data
sets you can use accelerated
accelerators like GPUs and soon TP use
to get the best performance and and
quicker turnaround time for your
experiments
and then we also offer capabilities like
hyper tune which is a hyper parameter
tuning capability to allow you to find
and optimize your your parameter space
for your best model the training API
takes care of all the infrastructure
whether it's compute resources or things
like your jobs as well as the as well as
the software stack in terms of all the
packages and drivers and and environment
needed for doing training on the
prediction side once you have a model
it's about bringing to you the best
production experience without having to
you having you to take on all the
developer operations and in hosting and
and serving models online
it starts with model management which
allows you to bring your models deploy
them along with different versions of
your models and it constructs an HTTP
endpoint that you can use to connect to
securely to your model and issue
requests and responses to get
predictions you can also use these
models in batch processing pipelines
using batch prediction these are I'll
touch on a few of these in the demo as
we switch it switch to that I'll be
demoing a sort of very high level view
of ml engine using jupiter notebooks
using a product called cloud data lab so
this is cloud data lab i've already
opened it up and i've got a variety of
notebooks like any ml problem it starts
with data it starts with understanding
your data and the notebook format allows
you to very quickly get a sense of your
data in this particular case i'm going
to be using the New York taxi fare data
set which contains data about different
taxi rights their their pickup points
and drop-off points and fares and what
we're going to do is build a model to
predict the fare so and all this data is
in in bigquery
so the first
you might do is actually understanding
it data and this involves first looking
at the schema which you can see using
these tools that we have in data lab
things like % BQ to to work with
bigquery api's so I can get a sense of
my schema I can also get a sense of my
data so this thing here has it's a
fairly large data set so clearly I'm
also going to be doing some sampling to
be able to work with it
in an interactive way here's a quick
query that that pulls out locations from
this from this data set and it pulls out
for every 10,000 rows it pulls out a
data point so that's my simple sampling
and then I can go ahead and plot it and
I get a fairly uninteresting plot but
it's actually interesting a bunch of
data points are at the zero comma zero
lat/long zero so clearly there's some
data cleanup to be also done in
filtering and so what I can do from what
I know that this is about New York and
so I can sort of bound the lat/long
pairs to New York and filter out all the
data that sort of falls out of that and
once I've done that with a simple work
clause that filters data to New York I
can I can re-execute this query I can
execute that sequel in 8 C cubes in big
bigquery I retrieve that as a panda's
data frame many of you are probably
familiar with pandas and then then I can
very easily plot it and those who are
familiar with the the geography around
New York probably can recognize this
this sort of roughly outlines Manhattan
and you can sort of see Central Park and
that's where most of the taxi rides are
at this data set so that that gives you
a quick sense of how I can use the
notebook to understand my data and to
know what what sort of pre-processing I
might need to do I can also go ahead and
build and build features like for
example I can use the pickup date and
time to construct two features day of
the week and hour of the hour of the day
and these are much more interesting from
a machine learning point of view to
understand and generalize across
different rides once again I can execute
the query and get a data frame I can I
can get a
preview of the data in that data frame I
can also get some basic statistics like
for example you know the counter froze I
got a number of unique values so this
here I see I have seven unique days
which is I expect that I can also see
minimum and maximum values mean those
types of things I can also do simple
things like understand the correlation
between fair amount which is the column
that I'm going to predict with other
columns for example distance and as you
can see it's highly correlated with the
distance again something that we would
expect but good to validate from it does
the data match the domain so with that
my next step is going to be around data
preparation and this is about taking a
data producing sample data sets as well
as producing training data and an
evaluation data so again I'm using
bigquery and it's similar query where
I'm picking out the features that I want
filtering out all the noise the location
as well as making sure you know these
were valid right and then I'm going
ahead and producing two data sets so
here's my data set that produces the
evaluation set and here's my data set
that produces the training data set I'm
going to go ahead and execute these and
export them as a CSV file once these are
in CSV file in goo in Google Cloud
Storage I can then use them in my
machine learning job and as a preview I
can also look at once I've executed this
here's the couple of files that were
produced in my data set and here's a
preview of the content inside that
basically it's the fare and a whole
bunch of features that are going to be
used to predict that fare this is just a
good sense good way to get get a sense
of your data before you sort of start
building a model it's also good to make
sure your training and evaluation data
are built out of the same same query so
that they're in sync so let's look at
going into building a model there's
traditional models like linear models
and these fall into a category called
wide models there's the new
up-and-coming neural networks which deep
neural networks which
which are also quite interesting in the
sense of they they are able to infer
learn about the relationship between
your features and then there's a
category that combines the best of both
and they're called wide and deep models
and that's what we're gonna go build
today the inputs for this particular
model are going to be the pick-up and
drop-off locations the time stamp and
the number of passengers think about
this as the types of information you
would have when went sort of try to
estimate a fare for a ride that hasn't
happened yet so here's my tensorflow
code I have this already in the interest
of time tensorflow offers a high level
API call estimators which which provide
all the necessary logic to build
tensorflow
models based on a given set of features
and set of hyper parameters so what I
have here is I'm building a DNN linear
combined regressor that's the wide and
deep model for doing regression this is
I'm predicting a price which is sort of
a continuous function and so that's a
regression model and I'm providing it a
set of linear features and a set of deep
features and then here's my hidden units
which is the number of layers and that's
a hyper parameter to my model here's my
columns I have my locations day of the
week are of the day passenger count and
then my deep columns are again the
similar columns and these and the deep
model the deep part of this model is
going to learn the relationship between
these features I can also add features
that weren't in my original data set but
synthesized for my data using tensor
flow so for example I'm computing the
distance between the draw pick up and
drop off points right in the tensor flow
model and so this logic will run both
during training as well as in prediction
once this model is ready so once I have
my tensor flow code it's actually fairly
straightforward to start using it
most developer workflows are going to
involve using your sample data and and
training locally and making sure your
model generally works so what I have
here is
a g-cloud command g-cloud ml engine
local train where I pointed at my Python
code that I was just showing along with
references to my data so I'm using my
sample data set as well as the number of
steps I want to perform training over
I've already run this but what I'll go
ahead and do is launch actually I guess
I haven't run this so I will go ahead
and run this so while this is running I
can start bringing up tensor board and
we can look at what's what happens as
the training progresses so you'll see
that this is the the training process is
working while let's bring them to some
data we can also look at the graph this
is the graph of the of the model that
the estimator built it has the DNN the
deep neural network part as well as the
linear model part let's refresh this and
you can see this that as trading
proceeds it will incremental e improve
the model over time and you can see it's
it's live it's updating and we've said
this to train over 5,000 steps it's it's
got about a third of the way so we'll
let this complete in a second
so meanwhile we'll go back to this
notebook and we'll prepare some sample
data that will predict / and this is
basically the types of instances that
will that will be used once the model is
ready let's see if it's done now
the model that's going to be produced
here is actually going to be fairly
fairly simplistic as well as not very
predictive because I'm only using a very
small subset of the data so an entry
interest of time I'm going to go ahead
and switch over to the next step while
this is still running which is trading
on the cloud now that's that's where ml
engine shows up and helps you actually
use much more of your data in in the
cloud so once again it's the same
familiar command I'm using G cloud ml
engine jobs submit and submitting a
training job and here many of the
parameters are same are the same as the
local case where I'm pointing it at my
Python code but now in the context of
cloud I'm also telling it where in cloud
which region for example US Central
which directory to put the outputs into
which is going to be a Google Cloud
Storage bucket and then I'm also going
to pick a scale here and here I've
picked a scale here called basic which
is basically a single node training job
and once I execute that this job will
get submitted
I can go go to the console and open up
so I've already run this this job you
can see the console shows this job you
can also look at the logs for this
particular job and this shows off the
logs including things like the loss and
the global steps as the training
progressed all output analog for you to
be able to see what happened like
like the local case I can also bring up
tensor board and open that and this
particular job is already completed so
you can see this particular job has made
it made it all the way through I can see
the loss the global steps all progressed
to the 5000 steps that I chose for this
cloud job as well now so that's great I
can go ahead and also use GPUs on the
cloud very easily so this is the same
same job all I did was change scale to
scaled here from basic to basic GPU and
now I have a single node training job
using GPUs without having to worry about
setting up GPUs or software associate
with GPUs and I can do the same thing
it'll launch a job I can go to the
console look at logs look at tensor
board more interesting in this
particular example is distributor
training so very similar again uh all I
needed to do let's change the scales
here from basic to standard and now this
gives me a configuration a cluster where
I have a master node that runs training
and evaluation a set of workers and a
set of parameter servers that share
state for the whole job and what the
what this thing does is it allows me to
use a lot more of my data and put a lot
more compute power behind it so let me
open up tensor board for this
so it's again the same set of similar
set of charts but an interesting thing
to look at here is global steps per
second and what I'm seeing is something
like 55 steps per second versus say the
other job where I had a single node
where I was getting about 14 and so this
is sort of the power of cloud where I
was able to spin up a cluster very very
quickly and easily for my job and be
able to increase the throughput at which
my training happens so now look let's
also look at what this job produced as
output all of the ultimata files were
produced into Google Google Cloud
Storage so these are this is where this
particular job stated all the outputs I
have my checkpoints which are
intermediate stages of my model as the
training is progressing in case the job
needs to recover and restart you can
pick up from the last known checkpoint
it also produces all the events these
are this these these summary files are
the ones that tend to bored visualizes
these contain a log of all of the
metrics that were produced but most
importantly you have the model itself so
here is my saved model and the set of
variables that were saved along with it
these variables are the learnt weights
so all of the weights of the linear
parts of model as well as the deep parts
of the model and and this is what I will
use to perform predictions so in order
to perform predictions I'll go ahead and
actually deploy this model so I'm going
to go ahead and refer to that model
using that path in in cloud storage
where the saved model was located and
I'm going to issue two commands ml
engine models create this creates a new
model called taxi fare and then I could
go ahead and deploy a particular version
of the model using what I what I just
saved and if I go to my console I've
already got a head and
and save this out so here's my taxi fare
model and it has a v1 model that I've
already gone ahead and deployed once I
once I have a model deployed I'm ready
to use it here's a little bit of Python
code to issue a HTTP request to this
particular model so here's where you can
see here's the URL for this particular
model as a as a developer I'd not have
to write any of the Associated HTTP
application code all I did was deploy
the model that was produced for my
training and I can go ahead and
construct an instance with the features
that I want to predict over issue the
response issue the request and receive a
response and the responses as you might
expect the prediction and in this
particular case it's predicting that the
fare is going to be 11 dollars
so as you can see I went very very
quickly from using tensorflow trading a
model locally building and training more
locally with us with a single
configuration change I was able to train
it on cloud without having to worry
about compute VMS and and resources or
job management I was able to go from CPU
only training to GPUs as well as from
single node to distributor trading and
then finally once I have a model ready I
can go ahead and deploy it and as as a
version try and try it out oh and this
API is something that I could bring into
my application and embed it in in my in
my app to be able to use this moment
model in production so let's that was a
very quick overview of ml engine in
action ml engine is part of a much
larger set of products that are geared
around helping you with your entire
end-to-end ml workflow and this ranges
from data ingestion bringing your data
in into cloud to managing and storing it
things like Google Cloud storage as well
as bigquery exploration data lab you saw
that as well as the power of sequel and
bigquery and then you saw ml Engine for
trade doing the modeling work and then
beyond beyond this sort of single
development workflow we also have
products to allow you to build pipelines
that allow you to construct models over
data as it arrives or over time and
updating your models in an automated way
and so this is sort of from data to
exploration to training to production so
with that to recap we have tensor flow
which is on which you can find on tensor
for our org this is the sort of Google's
machine learning runtime with the latest
and greatest api's you can you can use
ml engine to train and predict at scale
and you can use familiar Jupiter
notebooks using cloud data lab for your
data science workflows we're gonna we're
going to switch over to questions we're
going to take a quick break and then
come back to live Q&A we'll be back in
less than a minute
you
with questions from the audience this is
great to see that people have provided
their questions and I'm happy to take
more questions as we go along answering
the first few since the model is as good
as the data how do I tag a model with
the specific versions of data so yes
indeed machine learning is largely the
how good a model is is certainly based
on the quality of your data and and in a
sort of experiment scenario you're going
to try out charge a model with different
datasets one of the ways you might
manage your data is based on on dates
and partition your data along with dates
and you can use those dates as as as a
way to generate a version in in your
training program and as part of
producing a model you can also alongside
the model the same model that I was
showing also output some metadata about
the data that was used in particular
things like the date and at time of
deployment you can take those pieces of
metadata and produce a version number so
for example you know if if a model was
trained over the last seven days I can
take today's date as as an input into
producing the version that's just one
strategy you might have different labels
for your data set for example you know
like a production set versus a
experimental data set and you might
actually have names that you use your
your sort of that you use to manage your
catalog of data and that would be
another sort of piece of input that you
might use in in constructing the version
of your of your model ml engine allows
you to deploy multiple models as well as
multiple versions per model so you can
actually have for example my taxi fare
model and they can have v1 I can have
two and three and so on I can also have
something like latest I can declare one
of them as latest or default or I can be
explicit about the words and I want to
go use so that's a sort of an overview
of how am i do worsening
and and managing the sort of source of
data that was used to produce a
particular version of the model moving
on to the next question well training
with ml engine show how long training is
estimated to take so that I can estimate
costs it's actually quite interesting
and challenging to offer an estimate of
exactly how long any particular job is
going to take because it largely is a
function of your code in terms of how
complex the tensor flow graph is the
kinds of operations it uses as well as
the data that you have there's a variety
of numbers that sort of matter things
like the batch size how much data you
read on in every batch so so the best
way to sort of estimate a training job
is to run it and in in in the first few
minutes look at the throughput and and
and and see how many steps you're
progressing over a second per second and
you can sort of use that as a rough
measure to estimate how long it's going
to take for the entire job to run
through so that's that's probably the
best way to sort of get a sense and you
can you can sort of tweak the parameters
and see how they have a bearing on your
particular problem and and and the cost
associate with that correspondingly so
next question is ml engine tensorflow
only I use SK learn or scikit-learn what
what can you do for me so indeed I what
I showed today was ml engine with
tensorflow and ml engine v1 was
certainly around tensorflow and this has
been you can see a lot of momentum
around tensorflow
you can see when as Google open source
tensorflow it's but it's quickly become
one of the most popular deep learning
frameworks and we've continued to take
advantage of that and bring you all the
power of tensorflow whether it's
accelerated training distributed
training and and shortly TP use as well
however we definitely have heard and
from customers and and we want to
support
vast and comprehensive two blocks of ML
capabilities and that includes things
like SK learn includes things like
actually boost as well as potentially
any other framework that you want to
bring and so this is something that I'd
ask you to stay tuned for this is
shortly in forthcoming starting with on
the prediction side where you can train
a model wherever you wherever you're
running training today and bring it to
cloud to put it into production and then
we'll follow that with training as well
moving up moving right along when can I
get GPUs and TVs to train faster so GPUs
are available today I actually used it
and I showed how you can get started
using it with a simple configuration
that says use a GPU enabled cluster we
have both kts as well as Pascal P 100
you can also get not just sort of single
GPU training but you can also get two
and four for every worker and and a lot
of people actually use a single node
with multiple GPUs to really sort of
scale up their training TP use are
around the corner we have we have a
product called cloud TPU which is the
infrastructure as a service offering
with GCE
good and so you could you could you
could spin up a TPU node and use that to
get TPU training with ml engine you'll
see again a very managed experience
where you can easily opt in into TPU
just like I did for GPUs and ml engine
will take care of all of the resource
provisioning and managing that to the
lifecycle of the training job so that's
we'd love to of course hear your
interest please contact us us through
the feedback link that we have on our on
our Doc's page in terms of expressing
your interest to sign up for a TPU
preview tensorflow so moving moving to
the next question
tensile flow models seem complex where
do I start for my image classification
problem so let me answer that an in in
two parts
I will switch to my
to my demo code so tensorflow models can
can be complex in the sense that they
allow you to do new and interesting
things and use the full power of
tensorflow however if you're doing basic
things like a linear regression model
tensorflow has a number of api's that
will help you get started
easily so I'm actually going to show you
on my screen go back and look a little
bit more closely at this particular
piece of code
so what I've gone ahead and done it
brought back my code on screen and let
me walk you through a little bit more of
the code that I had for my particular
model so I'm going at an importing
tensorflow which is of course the
standard tensile foot package and here's
the estimator API so the estimator API
lives under estimator module and it has
a number of estimators DNN linear
combined is the one that I used
there's DN n there's linear and there's
more that are coming up and these
provide a simplified interface to all of
the power of tensor flow by a high level
API once I've constructed my estimator I
also go ahead and construct my data set
so here I'm constructing a data set
that's a text line data set because I'm
using CSV files and I can very easily
say I would like you know to repeat over
that data set for a given number of
epochs and read that in a batched
fashion without actually having to deal
with all the low-level api is intensive
though that are there and now for a lot
of power but but I don't have to use
them in this particular case once I've
constructed my estimator I can go ahead
and construct a training specification
which with that with that data set you
can go ahead and construct an eval
specification and then simply go ahead
and call train and evaluate and so this
gives me a simple way to get started
with tensorflow
now the question was also about image
classification now image classification
is actually quite interesting in that
there's a technique called transfer
learning that you might actually use and
this is one of the samples that is
available with cloud data lab if you
were to go get that there's an there are
some some pre-built samples that that
cover that use case the idea what
transfer learning is you take a image
model that's been trained over a very
large number of general-purpose set of
images and then you take that as a
starting point for your model and and
fine-tune that model with a smaller set
of more domain-specific images for your
particular problem you and the
particular set of labels that you're
trying to classify those images
and so that gets you started with not
just sort of pre pre built models for
tensorflow but also pre trained models
that have been trained over very large
data set so there's more questions that
have come in question says the deep a
part of the model prepares the weight
matrix to be applied in prediction which
is done by the wide so in reality what's
happening is the model consists of the
model architecture consists of two parts
hey white part that that sort of is
similar to linear regression and a deep
part that's similar to DN ends and both
of these are used at training time as
well as at prediction time it's the same
graph and the same set of features that
are being sort of used in both parts of
the model and as as the as the models as
the as the two parts of the graph
execute their outputs are combined to
produce the final regression or
classification what depends on model
that you have
so both both are used at prediction how
do I so moving on how do i pipeline
model inputs features and vectors and
evaluate performance and its accuracy
intensive flow so my understanding
refers to I have a pipeline of a larger
pipeline that goes from my raw data to
to pre process data so this is the part
that I would do in one of the data
processing technologies that Google
Cloud has so this might be bigquery or
it might be something like data flow or
if you're familiar with SPARC you could
use Cloud Data proc and these these data
processing tools would allow you to take
your data do the raw data and convert
those into feature vectors you would
like I did
you would build both training and
evaluation sets and and use the evasion
set to compute a set of predictions once
you have those predictions you can now
compare them against the expected values
and and get a sense of the accuracy of
the model okay since a model is as good
I think we've covered this one
so if there's any more questions please
go ahead and get them in
up one of these links for people to to
be able to visit the product pages so
thank you for tuning in to this live
webinar from Google cloud please stay
tuned for our next session which is
titled introduction to Google cloud
platform 4G suite users coming to you
live from New York City thank you and
hope you found this useful
good bye